hey everybody you work it against Paco
that's not the Euro twitch TV force -
games one my name is Dan you are
introduce yourselves oh I'm max Hobart
hey who is that guy
Jen [ __ ] here we got this new guy over
here what's up everybody Ryan McDonald
here
we're playing samurai gun and I don't
know why Eric today he's not sitting on
this desk because he you set this whole
thing up and we've got a prize going on
here what is this madness it's a samurai
sword and down generation to generation
so apparently whoever wins today got CR
keep this yeah probably from yeah I
spilled water all over this would debu
win so let's announce who we are first
of all all right
I'm the one far right that one jumping
around there in the gray with no pants
I'm the green dude I'm the red one
I'm this dude up here alright
who's the who's the black one on top is
that you like that really sure I just
got two fields one swinging store
completely horrible at this point oh my
friend this is madness this is sparta no
you fell in the water show your water or
you're gonna love shoes little squirts
of water on its B yes yeah that's real
life you only got one life left Danny oh
oh I only need one
you sons of [ __ ] oh you got a squirt
gun right that's working I'm keeping
tabs on this we've had one win - who is
that man he max I think we're gonna have
a showdown right here though because we
both got 10 kill low stairs
Oh what about me you might be it always
it's weird
oh yeah yeah fun first one to die and I
apparently I win good squish it squish
oh oh wow oh I thought you were gonna
miss Wow yeah that's how were you killed
me I thought here Dan's got two wins my
tactic is to stay the goddamn hell away
from Max and Jan Oh every time you might
have just like fighting
my house that's what boy kills yeah rows
one cup oh okay I'm getting some of the
you're gonna get one life I gotta
conserve I gotta consider I gotta
conserve my oh what a shock
I'll tell you what what are you doing oh
this was a death trap
this is no down there
oh what a shot icicle want this job
and gun cuz oh why am i no oh this one
sucks I don't get it I didn't shoot
anything I don't know no bullets I'm
gonna bow as the Sun Goes Down
oh whoa
you did not
ducky shot you didn't do that oh there I
am
Thomas that scared me
watch your back bro I'm out what's going
on oh wow
samurai goodness likes Yas
and now to get out
all your afflicted that boys I can't
tell him Janice is that no no no no ohh
or just lucky nice oh my god I think you
the genius today apparently that's my
tactic all right
did you see just your cards no I didn't
win that one Eric did of course I'm
gonna kill all three of you
son of a [ __ ] America oh just a shot
three empty gone there's come on
showdown 1908 cuz I got that thing did
he really get 19 there's no show I think
I got this one dude it's cool
I got it have like no reaction this is
what happens when you're 30
oh yeah yeah spikes I'm trapped
nice work bro
Erichs over there in the left no not
guys I'm not gonna be next
sometimes you got a camp your way to
victory sometimes you just hold I'm
still alive it would both die from that
how do we he does and then there was one
wait he's all right no he's hiding look
at him Dan will hunt you down don't show
down come on come on yeah it's right
nobody I got someone on the way up so
these bond points are not favoring get
you on the way up bamboo to save him oh
that's the worst Danny you're the word
yeah shot three boy was it worth it
I know it wasn't going to Jim oh okay
that wasn't me that wasn't you
this sort of 1/2 hour 43 your cell right
now I can't believe you didn't go for me
there
we clashing you Wow
wow you got blanks there what max ran
into them to Needham guys behind another
friend where is he he's hiding you died
you buddy
where's Eric whoa Nexus 5 lives
so where's where's Eric
oh no oh my god there you go
I've there better not be a showdown oh
you have to stop him you realize that
right oh shut up
it's all on your shoulders hey max
what's that over there 1 X 8 4 10 2 for
me and 600 Matt get one human that cut
zero
I don't know everyday I don't know about
every day at least I'm the sword you got
the sword over we're gonna measure how
sweaty everybody's has oh hey man
anyways thank you guys this was a
samurai gun apparently Jan is really
good at cutting and shooting things
just watch it air each other max is very
not happy he's probably gonna play a
bunch after this to redeem himself but
nobody's gonna see it I told him he's
gonna have him show well before the
stream started reading I was destroying
everyone doesn't matter unless they lost
it all but a big thanks to Danny - max -
Jan - Ryan who was here who it was
offset and Dan's over there so big shout
outs to those guys but a group follow
the view all the twitches will do more
stuff
later guys